the beauty of literature as opposed to
say case studies or biographies or other
ways that we often study business is if
you're doing literature that has
business protagonists at the heart of
the literature you see them not only in
their work environment and in
decision-making moments but in their
larger life so you see them at home with
their spouse or partner with their
children with their friends you see them
in bad times and good you see them warts
and all and a great artist a great
writer will take you and turn you like a
jewel a crystal showing all the
dimensions of a person all of their
vices and virtues all of their ways of
being so what I love about literature
especially when it's used to ask
questions about character and developing
virtue and developing moral courage in
the workplace is that it helps in a very
honest and very penetrating way show you
reality in a way that case studies and
biographies and other things that
supposedly are about reality can't touch
if you take a book like The Last Tycoon
for example by f scott Fitzgerald this
is the last book he wrote in fact he
didn't finish the book he died as he was
writing it so it's an unfinished novel
but it's about a producer in Hollywood
where Fitzgerald was at the end of his
life and it follows the producer through
a day of his life in everything he's
doing with actresses in the cutting room
with the people who are financing the
movies with the cameramen with you you
name it so you watch the masterful way
in which this great business executive
moves around in his world and you then
also are able to step outside and see
how he's doing in his private life which
is not terribly well
his wife has died he seems to be falling
in love with another woman
but he's really married to his work he's
working very hard in fact he's working
so hard and under so much stress then
his doctors are saying you need to stop
or you literally will kill yourself and
there's these popping pills and you can
see what's going on you know in his life
which again a great novelist can show
you which you might not otherwise be
able to see in a in a news report or a
case study so what we begin to see is
the lack of a fully integrated life the
somebody who is literally working
himself to death but doing very well and
you then need to ask could he do as well
if he had more balance in his life so it
raises the question that so many of our
students ask all the time
can I have balance in my life and
students argue that and debate that and
many say actually if you're going to be
that successful and you're gonna be a
luminary in in your industry maybe this
is what happens and maybe if he dies at
35 he's pretty young and in the book I
mean he's only in his mid-thirties if he
dies at 35 well it's been 35 great years
and he's done amazing things and others
saying are you kidding me you know let
him live let him you know fall in love
and and build a life outside of work and
have real relationships and so on so
it's a it's a wonderful book to help
people see a very effective business
leader but one who may not be with us
much longer
what I love is the opportunity to teach
this in the last quarter of the last
year as students are leaving the
business school they have a job they
earlier in their lives say we're
struggling to get into the right college
and then they get out of college and try
and get the right job after college and
then after that they try to get back to
a place like the Graduate School
Business at Stanford and then they try
whether at the Graduate School business
to get the right job for afterwards I
get them and say whoa wait a minute what
about the next 30 40 50 years of your
life now how are you going to find a
balanced meaningful life maybe it's
different stages of your life maybe for
10 years you need to bear down as Sheryl
Sandberg would say lean in to your work
for a while and know that some of the
other things are going to need to take a
back burner and then having another time
in your life where you have a lot more
balance between let's say your home life
and your work and you know you're gonna
take a hit in terms of advancement in
your work and doing some of the things
that you would like to do and then maybe
you come back later in your life when
your children are a little older and are
able to maybe do something different or
get back into the same career but it may
be that you need to do more limited
things at particular times of the life
cycle we're on a long journey hopefully
through our lives
it's an opportunity I think through
literature to touch people at virtually
any period in time of their life and the
beauty of literature great literature is
that it looks different the exact same
book looks different every 10 years I
mean we should take the great classics
and keep reading them so what you read
of the Great Gatsby for example as a 16
year old in high school is very
different from what a 28 year old
business student gets out of it and then
you get to a 45 year old mid-career
person or a 60 year old person at the
top of their career it's all quite
different and it's fascinating to see
how you know there's material there at
all ages I think it's wonderful to look
at the American Dream books and
Fitzgerald does nice work for us with
the Great Gatsby in the last tycoon
Arthur Miller the playwright has Death
of a Salesman or All My Sons which are
very powerful plays in this area
Flannery O'Connor has some great short
stories that help get at what is the
American dream
all about and issues of wealth and
poverty Jane smiley is a author who else
is very sensitive to these dimensions
and I find her work very helpful I love
to look at the existentialists like
especially Camus from time to time
because books like the stranger or the
plague or the fall are all pretty
powerful ways of kind of clearing the
deck and saying let's put spirituality
and religion aside and ask some very
basic questions about the meaning of
life and if there is any meaning at all
to life
the ultimate takeaway to me is the
importance of relationship the
importance of understanding that you
cannot treat other human beings as means
to an end but only as ends in themselves
and that if you want to really be
effective with all of your stakeholders
you have to keep your humanity always in
sight and that means that I often end up
the course talking about love and that
may seem very bizarre in a business
school classroom but ultimately I think
that is what matters that's what gives
people ultimate meaning in their life
and people who use love and try to run
their businesses in a compassionate way
usually do better in the long run and
the risk here is people who are trying
to maximize their self-interest or
maximize the bottom line for their
company often take a little bit too
short a term view quarter-to-quarter but
if you're asking in the long run how to
run a business well and be successful
then I think it's that relational
capability of carrying of caring about
other people which ultimately is love
that ultimately matters in your work
life as well as in the rest of your life